okay so the official trailer for doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness is
now here and throughout this video we're
going to be breaking down the easter
eggs in it giving our general reaction
to it and also talking about some of the
rumors on the movie and its cast of
characters we got a first look at the
film alongside spider-man now at home in
its post-credits scene and since then
there's been several action figures and
behind the scenes clips that tease
what's going to be happening in the
movie obviously there's probably going
to be some spoilers here so if you don't
want anything potentially ruined then i
recommend that you turn off now click
the thumbs up button if you enjoy the
video and don't forget to subscribe for
breakdowns like this every day without
the way thank you for clicking this now
let's get into the multiverse of madness
now before we get into the breakdown of
the trailer bit by bit i kind of want to
talk about the big reveals in it and how
this ties into the other mcu properties
and marvel comic books time codes will
be linked below though so if you want to
skip ahead then open the eye of agamotto
and jump right into the breakdown now
the big mind-blowing thing to take from
this is what appears to be strange
supreme from what if it's long been
rumored that he's gonna be in the film
and benedict cumberbatch actually did an
interview whilst what if was on in which
he couldn't show his face because he
said it would spoil some surprises we
theorized at the time that this was
because this variant of the character
will be popping up in the film and now i
think that's the most likely thing
unless they're also taking it to the
extreme and introducing his beast form
now in case you didn't see what if
strange supreme was a version of the
character in which christine died during
the car accident that originally
destroyed his hands spurred on with
finding a way to bring her back he
mastered the ways of a sorcerer and also
the time stone strange travelled back to
save her but found it was a fixed point
in time and that no matter what he did
her death couldn't be altered thus he
attempted to find a way to become
powerful enough to basically break the
rules but in doing so it led to the
death of his universe in the show he
absorbed several creatures including a
giant tentacled one that could either be
shuma gorath or gargantos who appears in
this teaser because of this he was able
to shoot tentacles out of his hands and
we actually see this being carried out
by the character during one of the split
second cuts that we get in the trailer
he was left trapped on his own come the
end of his solo episode but supreme
somewhat found redemption after he
helped save the multiverse from infinite
ultron and also killmonger left guarding
these forces it seems like his need for
some company could have got the best of
him and he's now returned to pose what
morrow says is the biggest threat to the
universe we also know from the action
figures that defender strange will be in
the film too and we'll talk about it
more in just a bit interestingly no way
home confirmed that strange was no
longer the source for supreme and this
title has now fallen to wong guess he
was in the white place at the wrong time
eh i'm actually like strange as more of
the kind of rogue sorcerer that's
destroying reality and for wong to be
the leader i think wong's just more of a
sensible character and someone that i
would put in charge and this would also
explain why he was handling things at
the end of chongqi a strange supreme is
a character that's driven by grief and
on the other side of this is wonder
who's still living at what seems to be
the mountain that we last left her at
after the events of west view she's been
living in the multiverse of sadness and
though it's never been confirmed it is
possible that this is wondergold
mountain that comes from the comics in
the source material this is actually the
location where the darkhold was created
at and she's been obsessing over this
long enough to grow an entire orchard
symbolically white blossom is actually
meant to represent peace and in
spirituality it's classed as being
something that shows universal
acceptance with life interestingly trees
that carry this are often called the
trees of light and symbolically they're
an opposite to chaos wander's magic is
actually called chaos magic and thus her
planting these shows that she somewhat
found peace until strange disturbs this
now according to rumors on the movie
wonder will be asked by strange to help
fix the multiverse but she'll discover
other versions of her children and then
turn into a villain that has the power
to destroy everything i think that in
this trailer the strange supreme stuff
could actually be a bait and switch and
we'll see he'll later become the main
villain in the movie i feel like marvel
is very much doing what fox should have
done with those those two attempts at
the dark phoenix film and that we'll
watch as she almost destroys the entire
multiverse trying to get her kids back
now that kinda ties into defender
strange and in the age of ultron graphic
novel we watched as the machine actually
ended up destroying the world in the
book wolverine traveled back in time to
kill his creator hank pym but in doing
so he made a world in which he wasn't
there to help the avengers during
certain battles this created a timeline
in which all of the heroes now pushed
the defenders as the main team and that
was the major group instead of the
avengers defender strange is clearly an
alternate version of the mcu one and we
could end up seeing an alternate
timeline involving him according to the
leaks on the film we'll actually visit a
timeline in which the ultron initiative
worked as intended and there'll be
several bots that help to defend the
planet now in age of ultron we watched
as this timeline was destroyed by the
witch morgan le faye who launched an
attack and it led to wolverine
travelling back in time to stop himself
from killing hank pym morgan was a witch
as well much like wonder and thus i'm
kind of thinking that they're going to
adapt several elements of this book and
change things up so that it fits the mcu
i think strange is going to be really
confused over exactly what's happened
with the multiverse and this will be why
he reaches out to wonder instead of just
fixing things himself if we look at
things from his point of view because he
no longer remembers peter parker he very
much has no idea why the multiverse is
cracked open because he doesn't remember
what caused it he probably doesn't know
how to fix it and i believe that this
will set up why he turns to her now the
trailer opens with dialogue from no way
home but also alternate takes from the
trailer involving the exchange with wong
it also carries across elements from
when strange told peter that the
multiverse was something they know
frighteningly little about from here we
get a close-up of strange's broken watch
which you might remember was a gift that
he got from christine in his first film
this had a big focus on watches time and
the time stone and it somewhat also
foreshadowed him breaking time open at
the end of the movie the fact that
strange isn't wearing this makes me
think that it might actually be strange
supremes and that he could be finding
this in the dark and dingy sanctorum
that we see him walking up the staircase
up i also saw it as being purposely done
to look similar to the santorum window
which is of course the thing that
strange spends a lot of time in front of
the shattered glass with strange at the
center of it could also reflect how the
multiverse is now cracked open because
of his actions and yeah it wasn't
peter's fault the spell got botched
large should have laid out the ground
rules before even trying it your stupid
sum of a [ __ ] now morta then says your
desecration of reality will not go
unpunished and we know from the ending
of the last movie that he's hunting
wizards we know from the action figures
that he will be called master morto but
i actually have a theory that the one we
see in the trailer will be aversion from
another reality potentially he could
have discovered the strange supreme
version and have come across to the mcu
to warn our stephen about how much of a
threat to the multiverse he is and
actually love to see it if murder
recruited him and he's the one who made
stephen go into another reality in order
to confront himself next we see strange
in a snowy new york and he then looks at
a skyscraper which has been split in
half on the left hand side we can see
the spire with the one on the right
having elements of it floating into the
sky this is not too dissimilar to what
happened in what if when reality started
to break urban and this could
potentially belong to strange supreme we
then get a shot of wander causing her
chaos magic to flourish and not too long
after a shot of her and her costume that
she manifested at the end of one
division if you cast your mind back to
the ending of one division then you'll
remember that she absorbed agatha's
powers so this could also explain why
she started to head down a darker path i
absolutely love this look and it works
really well for her when she's a hero
but it also works if she's gonna be the
villain at one point in the teaser we
see wong being attacked by something
magical and i do think that this will be
her later on we watch as several of the
wizards come together at camitage and
this could be her attacking much like
how morgan le fey did in the comics she
isn't in this shot at all potentially
teasing to us that she's the one they're
facing off against if you look closely
at the explosions they do have a red
tint to them so it may be her or it may
be a reach now from her we also see
christine palmer on her wedding day and
yuda strange standing in one of the pews
she's clearly not getting married to him
nick west is also standing beside him
who you'll probably remember as being
the doctor from the first movie that
strange told to cover his watch this
watch of course tied back to the theme
of watches and time and as i've been
saying it's all connected i've been
telling you for months now and you
haven't been listening but it's all
connected and you look stupid because
you didn't believe me you
idiot sorry about that some in my throat
now according to the plot leaks this
scene is actually meant to start quite
near the opening of the movie but the
ceremony will be interrupted when
gargantos attacks new york during this
strange will also meet america chavez
who has returned to the mcu from another
reality the film is meant to open in
another reality with her a variant of
wong and strange and a monster that
kills the latter two she will then
travel into the mcu and tells strange
that there's a dark terror moving across
the multiverse which will kick-start the
events of the movie we then see the back
of america's jacket which has a star on
it and from what i've been told in the
movie america's portals will open up as
stars instead of the typical circles
that we see from the wizards this
actually pulls from the comics i think
it'll be such a cool effect in the film
we do actually see what potentially
could be one of those portals even
though it happens so fast it's difficult
to make out but it does look like a star
shape now the movie is taking place less
than a year after the blip and it's a
bit quick for christine to find someone
and arrange a wedding therefore i think
that she probably met this person during
the five years after the snap and that
would explain why strange looks so
devastated if we find out that he
basically lost the love of his life
because he wasn't there during the five
years i think it'll add another layer to
the movie and i'd love that to be thrown
into the mix of the film next we cut to
a hatch door opening to reveal a
rotating universe where the gravity is
completely off its axis behind him we
can catch wonder in america so we are
definitely going to be seeing the pair
in this reality we then see strange
conjuring chaos magic himself in a
sanctum with a broken window in order to
stop chaos magic one might have to wield
it and thus it does make sense that he
would be going toe to toe with wonder at
this point now next we get a shot in
which gargantos appears in new york and
it throws a bus it's strange though
people initially believe that this was
schumer gorath and some people on this
channel may have reported that we know
from the lego leagues that this is
actually gorgantos gargantos is actually
a monster from the sea and initially
this was a name or villain potentially
teasing that he'll be showing up in
black panther 2 like he's been rumored
to we then end with strange coming face
to face with the darker version of
himself who says things got out of hand
we closed out on strange supreme holding
this pocket dimension in his hand
potentially teasing that it got out of
hand but terrible pun now i do say that
we can't always take things like this at
face value so it might not even be
strange supreme and knowing that
defender strange is in this movie too
means that we could end up getting lots
of alternate variants of the character i
think that would be the best way to
explore the multiverse and strange being
the villain of his own movie does make a
lot of sense if our theories and the
leaks are wrong now as for my thoughts
on the film i really can't wait to see
it and i love how dark that this first
look is one division was of course a
massive show and now everyone wants to
know what's gonna happen next with not
only her but also strange after no way
home sam raimi is also someone that
people in the comic book movie community
love and there's so many different
elements coming together for what i
think will be a massive movie
a lot of characters are returning from
things like the fox first and also the
extended properties that disney have
acquired there's also rumors that
there's gonna be big actors playing
variants of existing ones and we're in
for a massive movie that will have some
big surprises now you guys know how much
of a dc fan that i am and though people
are saying that no way home has kind of
killed the momentum for the flash i
actually think that the multiverse of
madness will do it even more from what
i've heard this movie is going to be
absolutely insane and we're barely
getting a taste of what's gonna be
happening in the film kinda sucks that
marvel will have two big multiverse
movies out by the time that dc get their
first one and with it releasing two
months before the flash does i kind of
think it might suck all the air out of
the room it's gonna be interesting to
see what happens as we now have two
studios tackling the same sorts of
concepts but obviously let me know your
thoughts below on the situation now if
you enjoyed the video then please drop a
thumbs up and also don't forget that
we're running in competition on the
channel right now to give away some box
sets all you have to do to win is leave
a comment leave a like and make sure you
subscribe with notifications on the
winners of the last comb edition are on
screen right now so if that's you then
get in touch with me on twitter at
heavyspoilers and we'll saw you out if
you're bored and want something else to
watch then we've got a video on screen
for you right now but if not then i
appreciate you taking the time to watch
this until the end and i hope you enjoy
the rest of your day i've been paul
you've been the best and i'll see you on
the next one take care peace